s'il est peu il ya depuis quelques temps
un mouvement qui s'est répandue qui vise
les femmes
une journaliste du réseau anglais si tu
utilises y en a eu assez aujourd'hui
qu'on lui lance des obscénités whishaw
nantes ne tolérait plus ne supportait
plus d'entendre une dizaine de fois par
jour les mêmes propos disgracieux
dégradant sexuellement explicites donc
décidé de confronter ce qui l'insultait
et depuis hier déferle sur les médias
sociaux une vague d'appui à shauna sand
et ce qu'il insultait eux commencent à
sentir les conséquences de leurs actions
c'est dimanche après la partie de soccer
du toronto fc que la scène disgracieux
s'est produite la journaliste shanahan
et tentait d'obtenir en direct les
réactions des partisans bundle quand un
homme lui a lancé des propos extrêmement
vulgaire et sexuellement explicites de
journalistes qui entend régulièrement de
telles insultes à confronter le groupe
d'hommes
la vidéo est vite devenue virale
c'est loin d'être un incident isolé
c'est même une mode depuis plus d'un an
des gens lancent les mêmes propos
obscènes à des journalistes aux quatre
coins du continent avec les fessiers en
estrie la reporter de cilicie shannon
martin soutient qu'elle et insulter de
la sorte au moins une fois par semaine
même chose pour chacune de ses collègues
à leur cause et ça ça me laisse à chaque
fois dit elle c'est tellement dégoûtant
la première ministre ontarienne a salué
le courage de la journaliste jon arnt
sur twitter affirmant que le harcèlement
sexuel au travail doit être prise au
sérieux
selon les policiers tenir de tels propos
des gradins est d'ailleurs un crime mais
les accusations de harcèlement sexuel
peuvent être portés explique-t-elle les
journalistes sont d'ailleurs encouragés
à rapporter de tels incidents a dit juan
a annoncé le congédiement d'un des
hommes impliqués dans l'incident de
dimanche
nous nous engageons à offrir un
environnement de travail où la
discrimination et le harcèlement de
toutes sortes ne sont pas tolérés
peut-on lire dans le communiqué
pour sa part le propriétaire du toronto
fc qui est également le propriétaire des
capteurs et des mets police entend
bannir tous ceux qui lancent de telles
insultes et aussi renforcé la sécurité
autour des femmes qui exercent leur
travail de journalistes ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto